do we build the bunker in the woods do
we meditate more
drugs some mushrooms psychedelics I mean
what uh lots of sex what are we talking
about here do you have to play Diablo 4
I'm uh hoping that will help me escape
for a brief moment want to play video
games what
do you have ideas
I really like playing disco Elysium this
was one of the most beautiful of
computer games I played in recent years
and uh it's a Noir novel that is a
philosophical perspective on Western
Society from the perspective of an
Estonian and he first of all bought a
book about this bird that is
in a parallel universe that is quite
poetic and fascinating and is condensing
his perspective on our societies it's uh
was very very nice you spend a lot of
time writing it yet uh I think sold a
couple thousand books and as a result
became an alcoholic and then he had the
idea or one of his friends had the idea
of turning this into an RPG and uh it's
mind-blowing they spent the illustrator
more than a year just on making a deep
graph art for the scenes in between and
so aesthetically it captures it stunning
but it's a philosophical work of art
it's a reflection of society it's
fascinating to spend time in this world
and so for me it was using a medium in a
new way and uh telling a story that left
me enriched well uh when I tried Diablo
I didn't feel enriched playing it I felt
that the time playing it was not
unpleasant but there's also more
pleasant stuff that I can
yes I basically feel that there is a
very transparent economy that's going on
a story of the Diablo was brain dead so
it's it's not really interesting to me
my heart is slowly breaking by the Deep
truth you're conveying to me why why
can't you just allow me to enjoy go
ahead go nuts
I have no objection here not uh
I'm just trying to describe what's
happening and uh it's not uh that I
don't do things there later say oh I
actually wish I would have done
something different yeah I also know
that when we die the greatest regret
that people typically have on their
deathbed at the state or I wish I had
spent more time on Twitter
no I don't think that's the case I think
I was probably uh have spent less time
on Twitter but I found it so useful for
myself and also so addictive that I felt
I need to make the best of it and turn
it into an art form and thought form and
it did help me to develop something yeah
but I wish uh what other things I could
have done in the meantime it's just not
the universe that we are in anymore most
people don't read books anymore